je vous emmerde alors là je
vous embrasse
une entrée qui lui ressemble
parfaitement un mélange de provocation
et de poésie pour ouvrir une soirée
d'hommage de son vivant
j'espère que je pourrai revenir au
revoir le feu de la feue qu'il ait
commencé une prouesse d'harmonie de
rythmiques et d'émotion sur les textes
de la paresse déjantée a vraiment que la
vie est belle selon bertrand belin
[Musique]
oui
comme
toi j'en veux pas
c'est prodigieux parce que c'est les
chansons qu'on connaît pour la plupart
depuis longtemps celle qu'on a choisi
quand on a eu on a eu la chance de
choisir c'est qu'on les aime et qu'on
est
qu'on les connaît de l'extérieur et puis
là tout à coup c'est comme visiter un
espace
la maison de quelqu'un quoi je porte la
robe vermeil
des pubs muté
soler deux heures de thriller poétique
moderne sous la direction magique de la
percussionniste lucie antunès qui a
réalisé cet exploit en moins de quatre
mois toute la complexité de de cette
musique et le génie je sais qu'elle
n'aime pas trop qu'on dit ça mais c'est
vraiment du génie et il ya du john cage
a dû piard enrayée mais il ya aussi du
lcd soundsystem g je la connaissais peu
en fait et ils avaient tous leur place
pour cette expérience philippe katerine
m jarvis cocker un casting hors du
commun pour une artiste hors norme folle
et comme le christ y vient p ar de bay